Throughout this lesson, we're going to
be highlighting different rules and
conventions, inspired by hiring
managers in the research we've done.
These are the rules and
conventions you should follow when
writing or editing your resume.
Please be aware that not all of
those rules apply worldwide.
Our research is mostly focused in
Northern America, and we know that
there are different conventions in other
regions, like Germany where I'm from.
In true Udacity fashion, you'll solidify
this knowledge with interactive
activities that will have you analyzing
and assessing yours and others' resumes.
To let you focus on the concepts
in that note-taking,
we've provided you with a checklist that
summarizes everything we'll be covering.
There's a link to the digital and
PDF version in the instructor notes.
The digital version links
back to videos in the class.
Let's get started.